I believe in the power of images I think
I wouldn't be a photographer I didn't
believe in the power of images I think
there's an immediacy to an image that
obviously text or writing doesn't have
they both are incredibly powerful tools
but they hit you at different moments so
an image that can speak to people really
can bring them to that place or
transport them to that moment of pain or
that moment of urgency or whatever that
emotion is I'm trying to convey in that
image I think that an image has the
ability to take the viewer there
immediately sometimes I feel like a
hunter I can feel like I walk into a
scene and I kind of look the first thing
I do is look at the light and I figure
out where is light interesting where's
light source and where is it falling and
then I look at the expressions on people
and their faces and I'm trying to think
about what is the story I'm trying to
tell or what is the story that's being
conveyed to me and then I have to look
for details I'm looking for sort of
anything that might be interesting or
might sort of convey a message and I
often kind of circle around that seen
several times so I'll look at it from
the front from the side from the back
I'll go around a few times and see how
the light changes if it's backlit if I'm
shooting straight on and then often I'll
shoot the hell out of it i mean i'll
shoot it every which way i can i'm kind
of very unconventional on how i learned
to compose pictures it was really trial
and error so for me I'm often trying to
fit a certain amount of information into
a frame I'm trying to tell a story with
each picture so that has a lot to do
with how I compose a picture and then
I'm trying to make it beautiful not only
even if it's a horrible scene I'm trying
to to sort of bring the viewer in and
make them interested so I don't want to
take something and make it so horrendous
or or capture it in such a way that the
first thing they do is turn the page I
want to engage the view
you